so here's something weird and cool about
english and languages in general is that
they have a sense of number kind of
encoded
into them um we call this grammatical
number
um and and the way this plays out uh is
in the difference between
singular and plural in english
the idea of there being one of a thing
or more than one of a thing
more than
one of a thing
there we go
and this extends throughout the language
and i want to talk about today the way
it applies to pronouns
so the singular form of
me
is me
right that's the singular form
the plural form of it excuse me
the plural form of me is
us
um
because you know there are many assuming
okay assuming i was cloned right so
there's one of me fine that's singular
uh but let's say i walk into like a
cloning machine
you know and it's like a part of it it's
got like little bubbles and it's full of
this weird viscous liquid and it shoots
out another david suddenly there's two
davids
may the earth tremble but we have you
know how do we refer to ourselves more
than one me
is us the grammatical number increases
i'm part of a group now or for a more
normal prosaic non-cloning example let's
say my sister and i are going out for
coffee i refer to the two of us together
as us
that's the grammatical number it's
plural
so it's important to remember when you
are writing or speaking
to keep singular and plural straight
throughout the course of a sentence or a
paragraph because you don't want to
mislead people into thinking you're
talking about something else
let me let me show you what i mean
for example i would say i looked
at
my
watch
i don't have a watch anymore do you have
watches do people still have watches um
i wouldn't i wouldn't say
i
looked
at
our
watch unless
i don't know a partner and i shared a
watch right unless like unless my little
sister and i both had the same watch and
we traded it back and forth
each month
which is pretty unlikely and kind of
silly
and so what i'm trying to say is that
our
doesn't agree doesn't match up with i or
my
this is plural
this is singular
that is a very strange place to wear a
watch what is that at the elbow all
right so we've got the dog wagged its
tail right uh
dog is singular
it's
is singular
i want to make sure these things match
up
we made
our beds
this is plural and this is plural
as opposed to we
made
my beds
which who has multiple beds first of all
but it would also sound like
multiple people including me were
assisting me in making my
many beds
there are two exceptions to this
and they are you
and they
and either one can be
singular
or plural
so there can be a singular u or a plural
u there can be a singular they
or a plural they and i'll explain more
about singular they later
the important thing is to be consistent
overall
so if you establish that something is
singular you need to maintain that
singularity throughout the rest of
talking about that thing
so if i'm talking about the cantaloupe
and here's a test can i spell cantaloupe
in real time without looking it up that
looks right to me
the cantaloupe was
delicious
in the next sentence i would say
i ate it
in
one
sitting
and it's not i ate them it's i ate it
because there's only one cantaloupe you
see that's what i mean about grammatical
number and grammatical number agreement
is you just want to make sure
that
this thing which we call an antecedent
links up
with the pronoun so the thing you say
before you use the pronoun has to match
up in terms of whether it's singular or
plural you get that figured out you will
be a master of grammatical number
you can learn anything
david out